today i'm talking to near chevit about
sparsity near has been long time active
in the field as a professor at technion
and mit and has also been awarded with
various prizes such as the good old
prize in 2004 and the dykstra price in
2012. he's also founder of a company
called neural magic that questions one
of the fundamental core principles of
current machine learning namely you need
gpus neural magic uses various
techniques such as sparsity which we're
gonna talk about today but also other
optimization techniques to make
inference on models like bert to be as
fast as a gpu on a regular cpu this is
pretty huge and can have vast
implications on where you can deploy
these models and just how expensive it
gets to roll them out to many people in
many places so today we'll talk about
the biological foundations for sparsity
why we shouldn't attempt to replicate
the brain and just what it takes to make
something go really fast on just the cpu
i hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you do give nier and his company a
follow and i'll see you around bye-bye
hi this video is sponsored by assembly
ai assembly ai does real-time and batch
audio transcription of audio and video
files powered by the latest advances in
artificial intelligence so if you are a
developer or work for a company that's
looking to get more out of your audio or
video data through transcription and
audio intelligence assembly ai is the
best place to go not only do they have a
user interface where you can just upload
stuff but they do have a very powerful
api but transcription isn't all they do
once your audio is described they
actually post-process it in many
different optional ways so they can do
things like speaker classification or
annotations of various forms inside of
your audio one feature i'd like to
particularly highlight today are the
auto chapters for this simply provide
auto chapters equals true on your upload
and assembly ai will after it's
transcribed your audio automatically
recognize chunks of audio where you talk
about the same thing give you a summary
of those chunks and a neat single
description headline of what you were
talking about there this is absolutely
ideal for anyone who does any sort of
long-form podcasting or videos like mine
where viewers are very very helped by
the fact that there are chapter
annotations and to have these be done
automatically is just absolutely great
so if you're interested head on over to
assembly ai use the link in the
description to let them know that i sent
you they are the single api to
transcribe and understand audio they do
so in batch and in real time via
websocket they accept all kinds of audio
and video formats and they do so in over
15 languages give it a try and thank you
very much to assembly ai for sponsoring
this video and now let's get into the
video
the topic of sparsity is a big thing in
neural networks right now mostly because
we have no idea really how to do it and
i think that's exciting times for the
future so uh welcome what what brings
you into the sparse world actually i um
you know i've been a
professor of computer science for many
years and i um
worked on multi-cores
for more than 30 years and
got involved in computational
neurobiology in the last 10 years
and one of the things that you really
see in the brain is really how sparse
its computation is it really is very
very sparse and and so
you know looking at neural networks we
see that there are there's a similar
phenomenon to what happens in
brains happening in neural networks
right where you can actually reduce the
number of parameters through pruning by
huge amounts and preserve accuracy of
the performance of the network and that
kind of says okay if we really want to
have brain like performance you know
sparsity is probably one of the tools
that we want to use to get there so
that's kind of how i kind of got into
this uh
yeah
and you founded a company that also
works into this direction right you want
to talk about that a little bit
yes i founded neural magic
neural magic was founded because what we
were seeing in my lab i was busy with
doing machine learning at a large scale
for
biology projects and what we realized
was that we could get cpus to run at gpu
speeds like at the time it was a pascal
gpu and we could make just a regular cpu
do what the pascal gpu was doing um
through the use of of sparsity and other
similar uh techniques and so we said
okay well there's a real commercial
value here for people because you don't
need an accelerator you can just do it
on your commodity cpu and that's that's
normal magic so what we do is we deliver
you know through sparsity and similar
optimization techniques um gpu
performance on cpus that is is quite a
promise maybe let's first dive into a
little bit about sparsity itself what is
it about sparse you mentioned the brain
is very sparse
yet our current or at least the way we
train neural networks is very dense we
can accelerate the dense neural networks
much better what is it about sparsity is
it just the saving of parameters or is
there something more to
sparse connections than to dense
connections what do we know that's a
good question so
clearly what we're doing today is not
the sparsity that we will be doing in
the future what i mean by that is your
brain is sparse way beyond the levels of
what we see in neural networks today so
your typical
brain in terms in terms of the compute
right you know your cortex is like a
cell phone of compute right but the
graph is enormous it's like you know the
graph is is the size and you need
petabytes to basically hold it so so a
cell phone of compute on a petabyte or
more of memory right but the
accelerators that we build you know are
designed to deliver petaflops of of
compute but on a cell phone size memory
their memory is very limited because
they use this high bandwidth memory so
so in a sense we're building the
opposite of what we want
right so if we want to mimic the brain
we should not busy ourselves so much
with the amount of compute and rather
worry about how it is that we implement
this very large graph
it's a very large graph but it's
extremely sparse that's the point right
and as you asked the sparsity is not
necessarily the same sparsely that we do
today through pruning techniques but
it's a combination of a very sparse
architecture
together with um you know a sparsity in
what we call in machinery in the kernels
right so it's not just that the kernels
are sparse but everything in the in the
design is very very sparse okay and we
don't know yet how to design
very sparse architectures part of that
has to do with the fact that machine
learning
grew up in the gpu world where sparsity
is not an advantage actually because
you're doing lockstep computations so
you win nothing by being very sparse and
therefore you know we don't we don't see
those architectural sparsity things yet
but
um but i'm expecting that to happen we
should be this should
come along you know and
and even more than that
what i expect is
things are starting to show up like the
the pathways from
models from google and so on where
even if you have a very large model
you don't execute the full model layer
after layer but rather you execute small
regions of the model at any given time
per input that's another form of
sparsification of your computation right
and that is what the brain really does
so your brain typically
you know when you see an input or so on
uses a very small fraction of its total
graph to do the computation
and so that's where we're headed we're
not there yet we don't know how to do it
but but this is the goal
and that's the old you only use 10 of
the brain
at any given time right yeah right
that's right i mean really from from
energy considerations it really is like
a cell phone okay it really isn't you
know this massive monster multi-gpu
thing that we use today
and
so my expectation is that you know
that as we learn more and more about how
to design sparse networks we're going to
see them become the standard they're not
the standard right now because we
started the whole journey right by
applying flops and still applying flops
is the the main paradigm
but we will see it appear both in
hardware and accelerators and in cpus
um this idea that we can utilize
sparsity you know to get really great
performance gains yeah that's coming
now is the question is a little bit the
chicken and the egg problem is the brain
sparse because it has the limitations of
the cell phone power or
does the brain only need cell phone
power because sparsity is such a good
architecture right like which which
causes which
yeah
um
so
so i would say that
you know the whole notion of parallelism
in the brain right um if you think about
it imagine that you need to do a billion
operations per second okay and what you
have are these very
slow chemical devices neurons right that
can do that right so you need a billion
operations a billion you know firings of
neurons in a second how are you going to
do that well what you need is massive
parallelism right you've got to get
massive parallelism if you can do the
massive parallelism you can get the
billion operations right
and and and so our brains are parallel
if you will because we have this special
medium right now on a modern
multi-processor right you can get a
billion or 10 billion instructions
executed you know per second
sequentially you don't really need
parallelism for it right and so what i'm
trying to say is you know the whole idea
of of kind of how brains evolved is
clearly because of the way you know
they're implemented but we should not
think of
of going and implementing this in in uh
in silicon in the same way right because
we really what we really should think
about just is that both of these things
are turing complete right you can do you
can implement the algorithm you just
need to know what the algorithm is and
then on silicon we'll implement the best
algorithm we can right
you know
of the of the brain but we don't have to
have the exact architecture of the brain
to do that
okay does that make sense that that's my
what i'm trying to say
you know let's implement the algorithm
but not necessarily the architecture
okay so when i say sparsity i really
mean sparsity algorithmic sparsity right
and it doesn't mean that you have to
have a very sparse kind of you know
silicon vlsi circuit to do this that's
not the case
yeah
given that we
that that's a good segue given that we
do have the flops right that we don't
have in the brain it naturally it is a
different a different system we do have
terraflops petaflops even in these giant
compute clusters
where should we put them in your opinion
like where where should that extra
resource that the brain doesn't have go
should it go into sequentially executing
what the brain executes in parallel or
you know where should we put that
so first i want to say
is that we have those flops
but they're costing us a lot and you
just have to open the papers to see what
the cost of the flops is it's enormous
an enormous energy drain and it's also
an enormous uh architectural drain on
what we're doing and so i would say we
want to get rid of the flops because
probably we don't need them okay and
especially as you go from the data
center
down to the edge
you get the your capability of
delivering flops comes directly at the
you know if at the edge you can put the
sorry in the data center you can put you
know your google um data warehouse right
next to a waterfall or whatever you want
right to a source of energy right when
you're doing this on your cell phone or
on a tiny device at the edge every
little uh
bit of energy that you waste is critical
for you right and so what we really want
to do is move away from the flops and
move more towards the very energy
efficient way the brains work because
this adding more flops is a momentary
thing for us
right so yes we can do this
but at a very high cost and no we don't
want to do this forever we want to find
ways to cut the cost reduce the compute
and
and and there's a little other thing
that i want to say and that is
architecturally
we generate the flops by running right
now at least by running many many many
tiny cores thousands of tiny cores
typically right in an arc in
architectures they require a lot of
connections to the memory this high band
with memory and this thing doesn't scale
so in a sense we're trading flops for
memory if you use the cpu today you
could get a terabyte on your desktop but
go get a terabyte on a gpu right and so
boosting the flops is going to enable us
changing the architecture if we don't
need so many flops then we can actually
increase the size of our memory which
will make us able to hold these giant
models that we want to do very cheaply
if you will if i explain a deep neural
network to someone i usually you know
you start with a fully connected layer
you say you know here is a layer of
neurons and here is a layer of neurons
and they have their connections right
and each connection has a little weight
and so on you usually describe like a
dense fully connected architecture and
that is conceptually i want to say easy
to grasp for people and so on do you
have an analogy for sparse architectures
like what is the conceptual like could
you conceptualize
to someone who doesn't know what like a
sparse architecture is and how to think
about it what is different
yeah the way we do sparsity today i
don't know what it'll look like in the
future but but today sparsi looks like
imagine that the two layers of the
neural network are these kind of there
are chords from one
layer to the next right there springs
attached and these are of course these
are the connections the weights that
we're using in the computation right and
varsity means i take scissors and i chop
chop chop chop chop you know until i
have five or ten percent of those chords
left right and those chords it turns out
right if i do this right if i do this
kind of pruning right
are good enough to capture
right the uh accuracy of the model as it
was before because a lot of the
connections are not important for this
process that's kind of the big discovery
and
modern research in in techniques for for
sparsification right um you know
play along this kind of game so you can
do this kind of unstructured thing that
i just described where you arbitrarily
cut in many places based on on the
effectiveness or you can also
structurally take things out so in a lot
of the modern models right we're
removing pieces that are not necessary
we do architecture search to find these
uh
these uh places to things right so
that's where the whole game right now of
efficiency and neural networks right is
the game of how do i cut this thing down
right in the brain there are certainly
some systems like the visual system
where that is clearly organized into
layers but there are many other systems
that have no
resemblance to layers there are
connections going up and down and left
and right and you know between the the
halves of the brain and all
is there a possible future where this
could become into like
a standard architectures for neural
networks that the notion of layers and
things like this isn't even really a
you know a thing anymore or is there you
know some some fundamental way where we
say no there's probably always going to
be layers but it's just going to be
sparsity between those layers so when we
look at you know we have a full
connectome of essentially only a couple
of animals a
worm and a fruit fly that's it and as
that said don't see a lot of layering
there it looks more like a mess
very sparse mess okay
um
and
um i would i
i wouldn't venture to think about how
what cortex what a cortex looks like
right
um we don't have that yet we're working
very hard to it's a very these are very
hard computational problems to be able
to
to go and get a model we just want to do
a mouse even a mouse is just too big for
us to do right now like a small mammal
right but my i would venture to guess
that yes the answer is that you know
it's extremely it's an extremely sparse
architecture and that it wouldn't it
will not look like layers
okay
you can impose a layer structure on any
graph okay it's not so the idea that i
say there aren't layers
sure okay i can take the graph and i can
layer it yeah i can do a bfs on it and
layer it but but the point is not so
much that it's more that by design when
i think about it right i'm not going to
think about it as a sequence of layers
where the change that i make is the
change in the layer one layer is
different from the other but rather
it'll be a combination of thinking about
paths different paths and i'll do
different things along different paths
that's kind of the idea you know if you
think about you know
there's there's
recent research from mit you know you
can detect um people can detect an image
in in
0.13 uh
set 0.013 seconds in 13 milliseconds
okay in 13 milliseconds you can detect
that you can say what an image is okay
this is there's no time for neurons to
fire this thing is is extremely kind of
parallel right and uses very little
compute and gets you an answer and and a
large part of that
is prediction
because you're already expecting
something so we need to learn how to do
those things and so machine learning
right now is in a very naive early stage
and so given that and given the things
that we are doing right now it's not
it's not a surprise that we're doing the
brute force kind of massive compute kind
of thing that's always what you do and
with time we're going to get better and
better at it
right
so that's kind of how i see this
progressing
speaking of becoming better uh if you
know the flat worm is sparse the mouse
is sparse the human is certainly sparse
yet our best models today are all big
dense you know computation hungry things
there is not
really a case every time i prune i
sparsify and so on i get savings in per
like you know savings in cpu or gpu i
get savings in you know my storage but i
also get like a little bit worse right
that's the common
thing today in pruning is that i get
like just a tiny bit worse than the
dense model i prune from
why do you do you think that is just the
fact that we prune from a dense model or
what's holding back the sparse models so
how about if i if i turn this around
let me turn this around for you okay you
can take you can take bert
uh
bass which is a common model that people
uh use okay and you can sparsify bird
base
um at neural magic we sparsified 95 so a
95 sparse bird base 1 over 20th of the
compute okay way beyond anything a gpu
does even if you run it with full
throttle okay it's just cutting the
compute so much that there's really
almost nothing to compute there it's
just moving data okay no i'm
exaggerating of course but but you know
it's really becomes a data movement
problem rather than a compute problem
when you when you and and you lose
one percent less than one percent
accuracy
okay
um and i say okay great so you've done
that you know and you've gotten all this
uh speed up but you've lost you say oh
near but you lost less one percent
accuracy but what i say instead is
forget that
take bert large a much more accurate
model several points more accurate than
bird-based okay and prune it so that it
actually
right
with 20x less compute it's actually
faster than birthdays okay
and so now you have the accuracy
right and you have great compute and
this is through sparsity so by
sparsifying the larger model i actually
delivered you the best of both worlds
little compute and great accuracy and
that's how i want you to think about
sparsity right it's a way of enabling us
to run much larger more accurate
dense models but because we specified
them we are you know
we're getting great performance
that's how to think about it
what's the limit currently that keeps us
from
we always need the dense model first in
this model in the pruning in the pruning
setup we first need the dense model then
we go to the sparse model we get
huge savings at inference time what
keeps us from just building the sparse
model in the first place
great so this is kind of the lottery
ticket kind of question
if you will um
there is research actually dan alistair
one of our uh
consultants uh neuromagic works exactly
on this kind of stuff
we know how to
um
to run um a training session right now
four
four models where you start out and you
need to do
only a certain fraction of the um you
know of the uh forward passes backward
passes dense and then immediately you
can already start pruning while training
so so there is research going in that
direction but you are right that right
now at least right in the in the
standard if you look at what's going on
there out there standardly you're right
we do most of the time take a standard
model and and from dents we sparsified
and so on but
but the thing to remember and this now
i'm not talking about the research
because the research is going to get
there you know yannick i don't know if
to what extent we will uh how fast this
will happen and so on but we will learn
how to build sparse architectures and
start sparse and continuous you know
it's it's really a matter
nature does this and so there's no
reason why we'll be able to do it but i
want to say something about today's uh
machine learning where where you kind of
start with the dance and then you have
to sparsify this is really not the
common paradigm
for most users of neural networks for
most users a model is is given to them
that you know from a from a known
architecture right and then they
transfer learn onto it and most people
do that rather than train from scratch
they really use the model that somebody
already worked very hard to build for
their specific use case and then they
transfer learn onto it so this is what
you can do with sparsity you can take a
sparse model and sparse transfer learn
onto it it's extremely efficient because
you're running at the speed of the
sparse network right so you can sparse
transfer and then you don't need all of
this kind of start with dents
and and we're seeing more and more
sparse networks um appear you know in
the in the in the literature and the
data in the you know in database
collections of
machine learning models and as we have
more and more of these initial good
sparse models right people are going to
learn to start with the sparse already
that's kind of commercially i think
that's what we're going to see more and
more of
yeah why
you mentioned this a bit already but why
are gpus
so
unsuited for sparse models and what
makes cpus in the way you do it
really suited for sparse models or are
they even suited or are you simply you
know
seeing that they're better
yeah i mean look the the gpu
architecture you know
is is designed for this very you know
small course tiny caches you're not
going to go and throw all that away
just because you know you found you
discovered sparsity so you're trying to
do sparsity while keeping this kind of
lockstep execution structure right and
this is difficult to do sparse you need
you need uh you you need you need really
a different kind of setup to get an
advantage out of sparsity now
now i'm not i it's not like you can't do
that right it's not like you can't do
that people can design
and have design
hardware that utilizes sparsity
efficient
okay there is such hardware it's just
not a it's not gpu-like it's not like
the accelerators that we have today um
but all of these again all of these
accelerators have a different problem
that has just to do with the memory
because of the way they're designed
right they typically have very small
memories so we're talking even even ones
that can run sparse right still have the
limitation of their memory size so the
reason that cpus are attractive is not
so much that you know that they
that you have a natural way of running
sparsity because you can run
asynchronous with large cores but rather
that the large cores
enable you very easy access to very
large memory pools right so the
advantage of having strong powerful
pores right is really that i can put
several terabytes of memory next to them
right and run
easily and that's where the big
advantage is going to be as we
understand more and more about how to
build giant models that don't run all
the model layer by layer at the time
right then the compute will be less
important but actually the ability to
hold that model in one place and run it
rather than break it apart on 8 or 16
gpus that's going to be your advantage
and so this is so i'm kind of saying
it's not so much that you can't build a
hard piece of hardware to run sparsely
you can right but you should build it
looking like a cpu in the sense of you
can access a lot of memory because
you're not doing tiny cores that's kind
of
that that's my two cents
so the the cpus are
good because they have you know fast
connect to large memory but also over
the years we've put more and more levels
of cash onto the cpu how much do you
have to have to take this into account
when you're building i mean you're maybe
you can explain a little bit what your
company does in terms of software you
build
compilers or can i just run tensorflow
or something
yeah so so let me explain so so so first
of all the the the connection between
the cpu and the memory is slow gpu has
faster memory and faster access to it
right smaller but faster right cpu
memory is slow but large very large uh
but cpus have a cache hierarchy as you
said and so if you you know how to
utilize your cache hierarchy then you
know if you're running in the l1 cache
of the cpu okay you're running as fast
as the gpu there's nothing there that
the gpu does that the cpu can't do once
you're in cash okay in fact cpu caches
are much faster than gpu caches and the
performance is better so
so the so the question then right and
this is what neural magic does is okay
so what we do is we sparsify the model
now you know if if the pro you know
machine learning is about okay
i need to
meet a certain latency and because i
couldn't meet that latency with a cpu
then we added the gpu and boom there's
machine learning with gpus now i can
meet the latency but there's two ways to
deal with latency one is to add more
flaps and the other is to reduce the
flops right and so sparsity instead of
adding more flops and hardware reduces
the number of flops needed in software
but now that you have this very sparse
model
because the cpu memory is slow
okay
then what happens is you hit a
bottleneck and it's very hard to move if
you do this layer after layer it's very
hard to move the data in and out okay so
what neural magic invented is a way of
running neural networks depth wise so we
have the this technology which we call
tensor columns where essentially you can
run okay you know you can break the
model lengthwise and run you know each
one of these kind of columns you know um
in cash
okay and you because you're not leaving
l2 really you're rarely leaving l2 you
know you actually get great performance
so in a sense right what we're doing is
we're using the natural ability of cpus
to prefetch things from memory and then
run in cache and because this you know
this cache hierarchy on cpus has evolved
over 70 years or i have maybe i'm
exaggerating 60 years of
hardware design it's a very very
well understood thing where people know
how to optimize it right especially the
big uh you know chip makers they really
know how to make these caches work
really well and so with these really
good cache
hierarchies um you really get great uh
performance by
running the model depth-wise so that's
neural magic you know we take the model
sparsify it now it doesn't need the
compute and now we run it on the cpu and
get speed because we're running in cash
okay and if you look at the numbers i
mean you know we we are you know at the
speed of of i mean
some numbers we haven't punctured we're
at the speed of an a100 even faster in
terms of how long it takes a four core
cpu can in terms of latency do what a
a100 does on a common model like bird
okay so it's really the the amp given
that it's sparse or yes yes yes by
sparsifying it and running it you can
make a four chord do what a100 does so
it's really now a matter of throughput
and the a100 has a lot of throughput
okay so now the question is you know how
many cores do you want on your cpu to
meet the throughput of the a100 and
again the story is that you know the big
providers are adding more and more and
more cores so you're going to be able to
compete better with the gpus
down the road so that's kind of the
the
the story of neural magic yeah
so the way i can imagine these these
tensor columns is that because i execute
depth wise the sort of values that i
need for the next step in the
computation are the results of the very
last step therefore are already going to
be in cache and since everything sparse
i don't i don't need all of the last
layer for the current step and therefore
you know i have it already okay right
and of course i'm i'm i mean you know
when you think about a neural network
there are overlaps between these columns
and the question is how do you deal with
the overlaps in a way that doesn't kill
your computation and that's the magic
that's the magic of it there's an
algorithm that allows you to do that and
because you can do it you manage to run
this way and you don't hit this memory
bottleneck and boom you're in business
yeah
so
for
gpu it's almost like you know gpus
enable us to do dense models but i think
also models have almost co-evolved with
the gpu so people have started building
models to fit the gpu architectures
better right especially something like a
transformer is like that's a that that's
like made for gpus um is there a type of
sparse model like if you if you could
wish for the best possible
sparse but you know there's different
kinds of sparsity like what is the best
type of sparsity to let's say execute on
a cpu if we want to look forward and we
want to especially build architectures
for that
yeah this goes back to your original for
one of the first questions you asked
right it's about it's about a different
structure for the neural network
execution so we should forget the
synchronous layer after layer execution
and think about the fact that you know
we can run through a model right in
multiple paths with multiple computing
units use the same weight structure and
so on of the model right but run at
different speeds and by running at
different speeds and and going through
the model in different paths i can get
from the same model
multiple answers to my questions which
is kind of what i i believe what your
brain does so what happens there is you
have this network but it's not like you
know it's all firing like this layer
after layer it's rather
you have these asynchronous flows going
through it right even going through
matching pads and cpus are naturally
built for this thing now i'm not saying
that somebody can't build a beautiful
fpga that will perhaps have a better
closer structure to what a brain does
maybe so but
but you know but there is an advantage
to being commodity okay the fact that
the cpu can do other things is a big win
if i can make if i can move everything
to software is really is the thing then
i can really get all the advantages of
modern software so i'm not pulling
hardware
accelerators i'm saying great you know
they have a role and so on and so forth
but they come at a price right and the
price for any organization is that you
instead of just downloading or shipping
your product with the machine learning
piece you have to ask the client to buy
a certain accelerator or run it with a
certain accelerator and this all goes
away if we can figure out how to make
the cpus do what the gpus do right then
we have then we're back into this
beautiful world of containerized movable
software and that's really
kind of where i would love machine
learning to move to rather right that we
would have and maybe down the road right
there is this you know
you know cpus have have a history of
absorbing the key components of any new
paradigm that shows up you know
virtualization started out with tricks
on a g on a cpu and then later on added
the features networking had special
accelerators and then they moved into
the cpu and i'm expecting that whatever
features are necessary for machine
learning to run well we'll move into the
cpu and we won't need an outside
accelerator to make this thing work
if you could um
so i think that's by the way also the
story of gpus themselves right they were
already kind of consumer-ish available
and then they can't they they absorbed
machine learning it's not necessarily
the best architecture for machine
learning but let let's say let's say
there's already all this hardware out
there right there is very good cpus next
to very good gpus
how do we get
the best out of a machine like this
right right now we've advocated for
let's move things to the cpu right we
have some advantages there but what if i
have a box with both like currently i
just use my cpu to ship data to the gpu
right that that's what my cpu does but
is there a way where i could potentially
you know what kind of architecture would
make the best use out of a combined
system of cpus and gpus
no i think this is really the vision
that nvidia has at least today for their
grace hopper architecture it's
essentially this there will be a cpu and
a gpu connected to one another and the
cpu will do all the things that are
memory intense and the gpu will do all
the data intense things the thing about
the problem with this kind of a model is
it's a beautiful model by the way i'm
not saying anything uh bad about this if
you if you really want to build a gpu
world that's a great thing to do but
again
the you know how you how much you
utilize your gpu your attached gpu
has to do with how you write your
application because you need to move the
data into the gpu in and out and that's
slow right you remember it's like it's
exactly like going to memory right it's
the gpu is not up it's not sitting in
your in your caches so if you're on the
cpu and you're computing something on a
cache and suddenly you get a page fault
and you have to go and get something
from memory that's the latency that the
gpu introduces here right and so
if
if you're going to design it with that
you have to create really good software
to pipeline things and this is at the
level of the application
so the application programmer has a big
programming task and so this is a great
solution
for large-scale big projects where okay
i'm gonna facebook is gonna get you know
a thousand of these or ten thousand of
these whatever it is you know uh or or
google ten thousand a hundred thousand
of these and you put them together with
then it's worthwhile to write this kind
of complex software but if you're joe
company right and you have your little
thing i don't think you want to be
writing that interface
right so so kind of
so i'm saying it's a it's a it's great
for large
things right data center things big
things but i'm very doubtful if this is
going to be
um effective at the edge if you can
um actually utilize the cpu for it
okay and and i will say one more thing
and that is that
um
you know
that
the modern way that
the designers of
hardware
think about it is that is mod it's
built-in modules if you look at the if
you look at the amd latest architecture
right essentially you have these ccx's
so so the machine even though it has
you know maybe 40 or 50 or 60 cores
right they're grouped into groups of
eight
right and each group of eight like this
is a little piece of the die okay and i
think intel is shifting in that
direction too so nothing's to prevent
you from making pieces of that die be
specialized pieces of hardware like a
gpu you don't have to have outside
device so if you ask me what the future
is going to look like it's probably
going to look like you know these large
cores right that have um or large
machines with with multiple dyes and on
these dyes we might have a gpu die we
might have accelerated and that's more
like what i expect to happen rather than
having a massive you know accelerator on
the side
if we
if if we hear sparsity and uh things not
being in layers and so on naturally the
topic of i think graph neural networks
is very close to that at least in the
imagination of people do you have
anything to say about you know where
current graph neural networks stand with
respect to sparsity
yeah i would think of graph neural
networks as a as a as a different kind
of
okay so so graph neural networks i i
use some some graphical networks in my
research and the and the idea there you
know is that
you know we can use graph neural
networks to solve graph problems that
otherwise would be very complicated to
solve if we tried to solve in brute
force
okay now it's not generally applicable
there are quite a few limitations
but
but as a tool i would say
that you know rather than think about
the neural network itself as being
looking like a graph neural network
right i could use graph neural networks
right
um to define um what we call motifs in
the neural network so for example when
we try to look at at how brain struct
brains are structured right when we look
at the graphs of brains and we try to
understand you know is there a motif
that is repeating itself in this graph
right then using a graph neural network
for that is a really nice way to try to
find these motifs okay efficiently
right um because the problem itself is
is p space complete or actually we don't
know it's it's a graph isomorphism so so
clearly we don't know right how to do
the brute force algorithm well
but but the graph neural network can
come to our aid here and so so i would
say that right now i don't really see
a a real
network design neural network design
that is specific to that or a way that
it helps but but in research it
definitely works and we really want to
use these networks to help us in
research
um
this might be a bit of a tech bro
question but if i hear you know i can do
sparse computation very i can reduce the
flops and so on um is there
any intrinsic connection between the
sparsification of neural networks the
non-layer-wise computation and
blockchain technology and smart
contracts and distributed computing and
things like this have you ever given
this any thought or or
uh
is that completely off
yeah
look i think nothing is completely off
with respect to maschine
in the sense that i am sure that machine
learning will find its way into into all
of those areas
right it's a matter of time
and
um
and right now right the all the work
there doesn't need the efficiency of
right of what machine learning offers
because machine learning in the end is
an optimization
and so
when i think when all these blockchain
algorithms and all you know become more
commonplace and we need to provide them
with things like security further
security or analysis and so on i think
then we're going to see applications of
machine learning there and with that i
think all these things of sparsity and
so on
are going to are going to appear
but
you know but but for me right
it really is
the whole story of sparsity right is the
story of uh of a phenomenon that is very
prevalent in nature right that
may you can say surprisingly or not
surprisingly shows up in machine
learning and it kind of
it makes me feel like it's strengthening
my my belief right that even though the
exact computations that we're doing are
not the same as spiking neural networks
and brains right that there is a lot of
commonality there
and the emergence of these similar
phenomena like sparsity like you know
pruning and so on and the fact that we
can get benefits from it this tells me
oh okay these are related i think that's
a very important
uh interesting point to keep in mind
with
neural magic who is your main
target audience like who who is
listening to this do you want to let
know like we are exactly for you so we
span the gamut from the data center to
the edge um
i would like to say i mean we just now
are moving into providing
the same properties for arm
architectures and so i would say the
exciting new thing at neuromagic is
we're moving from doing this you know uh
for amd and intel architectures to doing
it for arm which means that we're going
to spam again all the way to the very
bottom of the of the food chain if you
will and i think this is very exciting
because as you know because because
sparsity has a dual role as you go down
the food chain right because for the
large accelerating you know the the fact
that the memory footprint is large or
small is not that important but as i go
down sparsity gives me two things speed
with neural magic gives you speed but it
also makes the model extremely small so
you're getting a small accurate model
right running on a very small device and
this you know typically is an arm device
and so that's that's that's the audience
that i'd like to say hey we're coming
you know we're coming and we're going to
deliver the same things that we can
deliver for intel and amd we're now
going to deliver it for arm at the very
end at the very edge
if you say edge do you mean
smartphones do you mean security cameras
do you mean robots everything okay
i mean everything i'm not not like i'm
going to do everything to start with but
but yes
yes we're aiming in that direction yes
and with the danger that this has become
going to become like a a marketing
opportunity question but how easy is it
to get started with what you're doing
like let's say i'm a i'm i'm like i've
done you know my tensorflow tutorials i
know how to build a model and train it
and so on like
how much does it take for me to
transition or to to apply what you're
doing
yeah so you just go to our website go to
get go to get download deep sparse our
you know our engine download our uh ml
tooling and um you know immediately you
just
either pick a sparse model and transfer
learn onto it with our tool so we have
recipes you have a model you have a
recipe exactly what you would do if you
went to hugging face and downloaded a
model and downloaded a recipe you do the
same kind of thing and you
sparse transfer learn onto it and you're
in business so
it's not very hard
so i think this is really and we're
working on making it even even easier
this is one of our goals right is to
make it really really easy to do this
and the advantage of course is that you
know people are already busy
uh you know quantizing their models to
get more performance so this is like
quantizing in some sense right you're
going to do the same kind of thing
and get yeah a lot more performance yeah
is there a type of model where it works
particularly well and the type of model
where it doesn't like i'm thinking you
know convnets recursive networks other
regressive maybe you know the big
language models like what what is it
best at
yeah so right now you know it's best
that at bird yolo models we do we do
computer vision and we do uh and we do
the language models but not the large
language models we haven't done a large
language models yet so for those types
of things like the birds and the yolos
and the you know the uh whatever the
variants of efficient nets and all these
guys this is you know visual
transformers these are the things that
that we do right now and and every all
our technology is right now
you know available
for those um i'd love to do the large
models a cpu is a natural environment
for running the knowledge models you
know these giant models
these trillion or whatever parameter
models that people talk about splitting
across 16 gpus they fit on your desktop
okay so clearly a cpu is a natural place
to run a very large model okay and
so that's that will be a target but
right but not right now
okay very exciting uh is there any last
things you want to get out maybe about
neural magic or sparsity in general well
you know our our whole machine learning
software stack is open source and we'd
love people to come in and help us build
you know better sparsity use sparsity in
their models and and tell us about what
they're doing and you know that it would
we have a community and we'd love you to
join our community
excellent near thank you so much for
being here today this was very pleasant
thank you very much bye-bye
bye-bye
[Music]